should Christians celebrate
Halloween well a lot of people including
a lot of Christians they just think
about the
[Music]
activities they like dressing up as
ghosts witches or even demons or some
other sort of spiritual or mythical
creature they do it for fun to Trick and
Treat or to go to parties on the other
hand some people celebrate Halloween
because they want to remember de death
that is actually what Halloween was
created for some Christians even go to
church and they light candles on the
graves of those who passed away already
so Halloween was a celebration to honor
or remember the dead it was called All
Hallows Eve but many people can trace it
back all the way to the
pagans